a massive atmospheric River already  being blamed for two deaths as battering  California this morning hurricane force  winds been slamming the coast and nearly  a foot of rain is soaking some areas of  the state there's also concern about  power outages nearly 200 000 customers  without power now roads near Sacramento  are already flooded from a New Year's  Eve storm that breached levees  that water comes up real high again with  those kind of flows  we're gonna start having trouble  Governor Gavin Newsom has declared a  state of emergency now there is a silver  lining the storm is bringing more snow  to the Sierras and boy that's great news  because the Sierras of course are the  vital States water supply source and  their snowpack right now is at 175  percent of normal so good news for the  folks there let's see if it can last  have